[Music]
well another big star I talked to you
last night whoops Goldberg
remember she was targeted by roseanne
barr in one of Roseanne's retweets and
well you know Whoopie she is not one to
let things lie you felt the need to
respond to Roseanne when she retweeted a
shirt of yours that was doctored this
frickin show comes up every time
somebody wants to say something and I
just feel like you have to just keep
saying it's not real
meantime et has learned that talks about
a Roseanne spin-off are very much in the
works and that an announcement could
come as soon as this week Roseanne has
been laying low in Utah since posting a
racist tweet that prompted ABC to fire
her however it doesn't look like the
network is done talking to Roseanne if
the series were to move forward without
her
it could still need her blessing because
she's credited with creating the
character and could sue still our source
is optimistic that this is all but a
done deal telling et quote it is more
than likely the entire cast and crew
would return water gum oh no thanks I'm
fine so what's next for Roseanne the
comedian well that remains unclear but
Whoopi says don't count her out can she
come back from this I'm sure she can
yeah everybody seems to be able to come
back
[Music]